[Music]
[Applause]
might be the play of the year you don't
see that every day in the NBA
[Applause]
which
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
definitely job
slip Yanis plush at the rim another
flush
mr. potchuck yes
was over the head
[Applause]
thanks Bobo
have gone down walls five o'clock left
hand to hand
[Applause]
[Music]
are you kidding me
we're Yanis two-handed flush Middleton
up Yanis down flexo leaves it for us
nice movement made you good i'ii do the
best fit for this group of players which
impresses do the most you can't stop
that
[Applause]
back to us that's a beautiful place
great basketball
around for unis works deep into the
paint beautifully executed today
quickly up the floor for the posh
mention team in the league
plus he gets through there Yanis hears
the whistle
[Applause]
yes yes
for five hours
nice watch
[Applause]
put a body on that man
[Applause]
geez okay
[Applause]
that's the score beautiful tonight house
[Music]
[Applause]
or that
[Music]
be honest gosh
rather a reason gas
laughs
in short order that's why it's important
to stay close
[Applause]
Raja's what a beautiful pass for Yanis
on the plush let's get the crack it'll
hurt can't stop that
[Applause]
Yanis
[Applause]
the step over
[Applause]
bragdon can't get the reverse guess who
cleans it up
yes Detroit without to lob
17 mañana
[Applause]
giannis
they don't go small to him since he's
been inserted into the starting line o
scripted play
be honest effective beautiful city
yes lush be honest
well another done yes
another flush gumbo lost that time yes
yes for Middleton six yes
gets it back and fine Gianna Spartak
seven
[Applause]
plus 28
he was guilty
[Applause]
like red-headed finnish attend a cool
bowl express yourself
Yanis there's the power and the
incredible athletic ability there you go
[Applause]
since we're there on Christmas Day
[Applause]
[Music]
Yanis he gets by alligators
yes coming here as a coach
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
welcome to abduct out on booth
[Applause]
here he comes
and Yanis just flew in time out quickly
units yes
[Applause]
[Music]
give us a sense
[Applause]
- ability to fight game screens
I love over I honest wash makeshifts
headband got a flush
[Applause]
where's
plus I'm the Kubo Lopez boy honest
[Applause]
flashing Miss Middleton Yanis nice
Janice from Bledsoe
[Applause]
the former commanders are added to the
same team twice then what happened he
gets free
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and look out rim
and then he can find a seam and get
through it Durga to be honest be honest
against Dorian finney-smith
University of Wisconsin Devin Harris
Janus heart janus janus flush
[Music]
[Applause]
Yanis to the left spin right wash
[Applause]
too short to go on this red power back
to 14 with that offensive rebound and
iwere Street
so exciting to watch
[Applause]
getting back
yeah mrs. there
get it back
loop top brass shooting in the first
corner
well done inside Yanis Russo Janice
beautiful pass to Toronto keeps up with
them again this finishes ferociously
I don't know that I've ever seen
somebody who finishes with their offhand
as ferociously as Yanis
[Applause]
Janice in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes Janice will become paint bathroom
getting it to the playoffs
yes to players all the things we've been
talking about
he takes baton to the rim and the final
he did it against the bunch Janis on a
flush kicks fire I'll do with the head
to do stairs
[Applause]
be honest concealing in service from
blood so the wanting this second leading
guy you know he's struggling
Simmons on lockdown he said that with
his chest
was impressive and with 15 rebounds
Yanis now with 52
yes you thought about settling a bad
shot three-point shots pass the game has
slowed down from the night yes
today
explosively hammers oh my goodness manis
brushes hand of
he would appear yes
he said 3d and there's there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first hand down
[Applause]
[Music]
for me
[Applause]
what opposite starter
[Applause]
yes
he works in Spain
yes
[Applause]
let's play
[Applause]
waiting game over the pistons did you
see where he took off oh my goodness
he really is a freak physically that guy
[Applause]
beautiful position nothing to do with
that so long done what we said made a
great steal but right to the long nights
showing go by Yanis all in the body of a
Greek god
it's inside and again congestus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what Joe taught us to just check back
here what up at you boy Adam left go do
you like that content I know you like
that content hit subscribe for more of
it from Bleacher Report